why are these animated films making me
feel these feelings
salutations everyone and welcome to
another episode of what's up disney plus
where we talk about all things disney
plus
i'm jenny and i'm andre we've got an
exciting lineup for you today with
superheroes
25 years of talking toys even a
hair-raising
anniversary let's get into it
marvel's 616 is coming to disney plus
tomorrow and it is absolutely wild how
much marvel has
shaped pop culture which makes me want
to talk about it so
what are some of your favorite moments
favorite characters andre i grew up
with the marvel characters through
cartoons so like the old
classic spider-man and spider-man and
his amazing friends and then the 90s
spider-man cartoon and the x-men
cartoons our grocery store had one comic
book rack
so i would always go over there and try
to read as much of the comics as i could
i get a little bit of hulk in a little
bit of iron man a little bit of captain
america
what about you the entire universe right
now is swirling through my brain
i'm such a huge fan of scarlet witch
and they did such a great job with her
portrayal
in the mcu i also was introduced to the
characters via the
saturday morning cartoons i was a late
bloomer technically when it comes to the
comics but
it's never too late i say never too late
that's right
and jenny i believe you spoke with some
of the filmmakers
of marvel 616 right i sure did let's
take a look
we're here with allison brie gillian
jacobs jason sturman and paul
scheer first of all tell us exactly what
marvel's
616 is all about marvel 616 is a
documentary series with different
filmmakers different viewpoints
different genres themes style elements
which
basically looks at marvel's history and
marvel's universe of characters
and influence on the real world what
about marvel's female characters
inspires you the most and how do you
hope it will resonate with future
generations of fans
what resonated with me about them were
their vulnerabilities
struggling in terms of figuring out who
they are
discovering their own self-worth how to
empower themselves within the context of
being a superhero and knowing that you
might have to get through
some tough times in order to come out on
the other side a better and more
confident person
yeah i think it's also really exciting
to see these characters leading their
own
series whether it is squirrel girl or ms
marvel captain marvel
there are so many exciting characters
and
i find that really inspiring there's so
much marvel content out there
what makes this series unique it is
probably uncovering parts of marvel that
you don't know
and you are in for an intriguing ride
because each one of these
is incredibly different but yet they
share one thing
amazing creators telling stories that
they're passionate about and
worlds that mean a lot to them so alison
since your episode marvel spotlight is
about a high school
we're gonna play a fun game where we get
to find out
which marvel comics characters best fit
these high school superlatives
which marvel character is most likely to
become your best friend
the instant you meet squirrel girl
squirrel girl
actually that is a great answer and
let's just pretend it came from me
because i totally agree i'm gonna go
with the classic answer which is peter
parker i feel like peter
is the most open he wants to make
friends he wants to belong
which marvel character is most likely to
kick you out of a group project
loki read my mind gilbert are really
mind-melding
during this game black widow she would
not like me
you know going off on tangents and
making jokes i'm assuming tony stark
because he has nothing i have nothing to
contribute to anything at his level of
science
[Laughter]
which marvel hero is the best
motivational speaker
kamala khan writes great fanfic so maybe
she could
turn that into a motivational speech
group can really convey a lot with i am
group so he seems to
move people with three words so
very clear and concise which marvel
character would have the best
tick-tock i don't think there's a more
clever
character than deadpool i believe they
would probably be the funniest because
you'd also get some superhero bloopers
in there
as well the hulk um
just like a great surprise at the end of
his tick tock you know it would probably
be a tie between
you know ms marvel and and miles morales
spider-man
since they both are probably closer to
the tick-tock generation i agree with
jason on that one miles and kamala
i'm sticking by my whole cancer if he
doesn't smash his iphone
every time he tries to record a tick
tock that's what would make it
interesting can get frustrating that app
which marvel hero would win best dressed
i like the captain marvel
redesign the recent incarnation of carol
danvers are you wearing a captain marvel
shirt there
i am thank you guys
so much for being on the show and all of
you at home
you can start streaming marvel's 616
tomorrow on disney plus
surprise you filthy animals home alone
home alone 2 lost in new york and
hubaloo 3 are now streaming on disney
plus
season streamings this week we got a
trailer for high school musical the
musical the holiday special
and even a sneak peek at high school
musical the musical the series
season two we also got a new trailer for
godmother the holiday comedy starring
isla fisher and jillian bale which
starts streaming december 4th
we have something super rad for all you
fortnite fans out there
fortnite and disney plus are
collaborating to give you an amazing
deal
for a limited time you can get up to two
months of disney plus with any fortnight
real money in-game purchase
also fortnite is putting star wars and
marvel skins
into the game so to give us some tips on
how to use those skins and also maybe be
better fortnite players is the fortnite
world cup champion
booga what's up booga what's up everyone
it's so good to see you well
congratulations you gotta tell me how it
feels to be
a fortnight world cup champion it's not
even a feeling i could probably describe
it's just you're in the moment you have
all this adrenaline rushing around you
i loved it oh it's so cool so i gotta
ask about your name
where did the name booga come from okay
so the name booga
it came from my grandpa uh i was a
little baby and he was like
booga booga booga i pretty much just
inherited that nickname then and then
just
had it ever since so that's so awesome
so disneyplus and fortnite are doing
this collaboration where you have
all these different star wars and marvel
skins in the game you got characters
like wolverine and captain america
rey finn and storm troopers how do you
feel about seeing these characters
in fortnight i think it's super sick
like first starting out playing fortnite
they were just all those default skins
there was nothing much to it but then
you watch all these shows see all these
super cool ideas and characters and
you're just like
oh i wish one day they'd implement this
into my favorite game and here we are
now with all these six skins on all the
characters have you been able to come up
with any different tips now do you have
these specific skins
yeah so for example at one of the places
called stark industries
the character actually gives you a key
card and
you can put that in and get a bunch of
good loots stark's always helping out
so disney plus of course has a lot of
movies do you have a favorite
disney or marvel or star wars or pixar
movie my favorite
would be toy story i grew up watching
that i mean
it's just been my favorite ever since i
love all the characters i love
everything about it the story that's
appropriate because we're actually
celebrating the 25th anniversary of toy
story right now so
you picked a great film there maybe it's
because the toy boxes kind of look like
they could be loot boxes is that what it
is
probably yeah nice thank you so much
again congratulations
and thank you for hanging out with us
here today awesome thank you guys for
having me
and if you want to take part in this
awesome deal go to fortnight.com
disney plus to redeem your subscription
with any fortnight real money in game
purchase
star command come in do you read
november
22nd marks the 25th anniversary of
disney and pixar's
toy story oh wow where have all the
years gone
i actually remember the first time i
watched toy story i was so excited to
see this movie
just because i loved animation so it was
going to be interesting to see a fully
cg animated movie
and wow was i impressed and of course
feeling like oh
is this what my toys do what i'm doing
i'm not gonna lie that was my belief
for a very long time it was a very
convincing
film when i first saw it i saw it so
many times and i really
i used to treat my toys very poorly oh
are you a sid
maybe let's go home and play
just maybe but as i aged
i just cried more and more with every
sequel
right yeah it's just amazing that this
franchise has been around for
25 years with four movies even a number
of shorts along the way and we thought
it'd be a little bit of extra fun to go
back
in time and check out some of the photos
from the
first toy story film so let's take a
look at these
oh my gosh look at that it's tim allen
and tom hanks
woody and buzz together wow those 90s
clothes
all jean everything yes
oh look at okay okay he's recording
for woody but it seems like he's about
to sing his next 90s pop hit right there
he's got the hand on the headphones
you gotta find him me me
it does it looks very uh boybandish
there's tim allen doing his buzz light
here whoa he's like
really far from the mic he's probably
having a shouting scene there to
infinity and beyond yeah
there's so much that goes into voice
acting you're using your body yeah
anything you can do to bring that
character to life
oh there there's the whole gang such a
wonderful cast of people that worked on
this yeah it's
fascinating how it all comes together so
awesome to see those nostalgic flashback
photos
thank you toy story for 25 years
so cool and take care of your toys out
there everyone
yes some of mine are still unboxed
i feel like big al i'm sorry
all right jenny it's time for us to
light up our lanterns because we are
celebrating a very special occasion
november 24th is the 10th anniversary of
walt disney animation studios
tangled i love that movie it is so good
it's actually one of my favorite movies
and you know who i love with all my
heart and soul
pascal i like maximus the horse he's so
cool hilarious what an attitude
but now we get to talk to the director
of the film byron howard
thank you for being here byron happy
tangled anniversary
thank you thank you for having me well
fans are forever obsessed with tangled
so how does it feel to have created
something
so special 10 years later it is pretty
incredible like when we were
all coming up with the film we all
talked and said well maybe if we do our
job right maybe they'll actually build
one of these towers in one of the parks
and
they they're there so the first time
that happened that
blew my mind and this whole team of
people that came together and created
this was very very special
and then to see it come out into the
world and see that the world started to
embrace disney musicals again was
monumental
that's fantastic and is there a favorite
moment from behind the scenes of tangled
that you remember
yes okay so this is what nobody knows
this get ready disney fans for the
inside scoop
you ready you're coming i'm ready when
it came time
to cast some of the secondary characters
like the pub thugs our casting director
came to nathan and me and they said
who would you guys love anyone anyone in
the world anyone in hollywood you would
want
to play a pub thug and so my choice was
anybody know who richard keel is wait
jaws from the bond movies
oh yes jaws from the bond movies that is
correct sir
that's like jamie if you could get him
to play vlad
a huge thug that loves tiny unicorns
this would be
him yes he's seven foot two big great
guy
reached out with his huge hand shook my
tiny hand i want that guy
that guy yes yes dreams come true in the
movie and behind the scenes
that's right we have to play a little
bit of a game here because
there's a fun tip that rapunzel's hair
entangled is about
70 feet long that is correct i got a
list of some
real life objects and locations some of
which are
over 70 feet and some of which are under
70 feet
so we're going to get you to guess with
each one if you think it's over or
under the length of rapunzel's hair all
right let's do it
the length of a bowling lane oh
that's tricky i thought you guys are
going to be easier than me that
i would say shorter than 70 feet
that's correct yes yes the distance
between the bases
on a baseball diamond i'm trying to
think i played baseball badly when i was
a kid how many steps do i have to take
more than 70 yeah
90 feet the height of cinderella's
castle
in magic kingdom park at walt disney
world resort
oh in florida cast member yes i know
this
i think it's 183 feet 180 something
[Music]
yes the length of an olympic sized pool
yeah
less oh
it's okay i'll bring it back
yes 164 feet for the pool oh yeah
yeah i told him all right here's a
marvel one for you
yeah well you know you're in for it
because i just recently watched the
entire marvel universe from front to
back so
prepare yourself for a correct answer
all right we'll see
the height to which ant-man grows in
marvel studios captain america civil war
i am guessing that it is less than 70
feet
that is correct yes
60 feet high five to marvel clink nice
job i've underestimated your guys guile
you guys chose ones that were very close
you got most of those right though that
was really good thank you guys it was
really fun oh
thank you thank you for tagling yes
tangled everybody
amazing team made this film should we
end off with the smolder oh man okay
[Music]
wow we had a lot of fun today it was an
absolute blast and everyone watching
be sure to like comment subscribe and
share and head on over to disney plus
where you can stream all of your
favorites we'll see you soon
we will see you next week but jenny i i
want to learn me but i think rapunzel
just moved
don't play with me andre if she takes
out a frying pan
please let me know it's all right i'll
give it a smolder
at last